good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight joe biden's publicist
just announced with a straight face he
plans to run again
in 2024.
we'll address that at some length
tomorrow but
first another crisis in the news so
after the killings in buffalo and uvalde
a few weeks ago you begin to hear people
on television talk about something
called red flag laws the government they
informed us could actually end mass
shootings tomorrow simply by taking the
guns away from mass shooters before they
commit mass shootings it's not
complicated
in fact it's such an obvious solution
that you had to wonder why we weren't
already doing that
who doesn't want to prevent mass
shootings well only the gun lobby
everybody else cares about children
so a lot of americans not surprisingly
now say they want red flag laws and why
wouldn't they like supporting black
lives matter or fighting climate change
or getting the kovid shot or standing
with the brave people of ukraine
red flag laws seem like one of those
ideas that no decent person could
possibly oppose
you want crazy people to have guns of
course you don't who would so naturally
you're for red flag laws and in fact we
may soon get red flag logs across the
country
so what would that mean if we do well
two things you should know first red
flag laws will not end mass shootings
but red flag laws will end due process
due process is a simple concept but it's
the key to everything that is good about
america in our system of justice
citizens cannot be punished without
first being charged with a crime
politicians cannot just decide to hurt
you throw you in handcuffs lock you in
jail seize your property simply because
they don't like how you think or how you
vote no before they punish you they have
to go through a formal process in which
they describe
which specific law you broke and exactly
how you broke it they have to prove it
for serious crimes with big penalties
the government has to convince a group
of your fellow citizens first it's
called a grand jury and this government
must convince them that you deserve to
be punished or they cannot proceed
none of this is new this is the way
we've done things in america for more
than 200 years and it's exactly why we
have and have always had the fairest
justice system in the world people moved
this country from all over the globe to
benefit from it
but red flag laws will end this
under red flag laws the government
doesn't have to prove you did anything
wrong in order to strip you of your most
basic rights
all that's required to punish you is a
complaint possibly even an anonymous
complaint in which somebody says you
seem dangerous
now that complaint doesn't come from a
grand jury it can come from anyone
including someone who hates you or
someone who simply doesn't like your
politics it doesn't matter because no
jury will ever see it
on the basis of that unproven complaint
you lose your freedom and your ability
to defend yourself and your family
now how could that possibly happen in
this country well the supreme court has
said unequivocally that it can't happen
here
a year ago the supreme court ruled in a
case called coniglia versus strong
police in rhode island had seized the
personal firearms of a 68 year old man
whose wife had called in a complaint
against him after they had an argument
that man had committed no crime he'd
never been convicted of the crime and he
was judged by doctors to be sane and yet
the authorities took away his guns
anyway he sued under the fourth
amendment and the case went all the way
to the supreme court the result was not
even close
the supreme court sided with the gun
owner in that case in a rare nine zero
decision that means that every justice
liberal and conservative agreed that
authorities cannot just seize your
property or throw you in jail because
they don't like the way you look or
because someone is mad at you
so red flag laws are unconstitutional
period we don't need to guess about that
and yet the bible administration is
pushing them anyway why because they
don't care
how is joe biden able to ignore a
supreme court decision from last year
simple he declares an emergency and does
what he wants he's done it before the
white house did the same thing with the
eviction moratorium and vaccine mandates
last year it's an emergency we don't
have time for due process
so you can see why democrats love
emergencies nothing gives them more
power more quickly
they've declared the atrocities in
uvalde in buffalo an emergency unlike
the daily mass shootings in baltimore
and chicago cities they run and whose
killings they therefore assiduously
ignore and in the base of that emergency
they can move forward with gun
confiscation
so the white house now wants congress to
pass a law paying the states to enact
red flag laws and here's the amazing
part at least 10 republican senators are
backing this effort from the biden white
house and that means this is virtually
guaranteed to pass
what's their reasoning well here's one
of those senators john cornyn of texas
you have colleagues on the other in the
other chamber who are already coming out
against this before you even put out a
proposal i'm not surprised
some people
will not want to touch this with a
10-foot pole
because they're concerned about the
politics of it but i think this is a
time where hopefully we can transcend
that
personal political interest and do what
we think will save lives to me that's
the ultimate goal we can do something
sensible that does not undermine
the rights of law-abiding citizens under
the constitution to keep and bear arms
so there are two things to notice about
that sound bite which is so revealing
the first is the use of the term
sensible now that is a democratic
talking point approved by the dnc it's
sensible gun safety regulation so here
you have john cornyn taking nancy
pelosi's language he's doing it on
purpose
and then you hear him describe anyone
who disagrees with him why would you
disagree with john cornell according to
john cornyn anyone who disagrees with
them is quote concerned about the
politics of red flag laws not the wisdom
of red flag laws not whether or not red
flag laws are constitutional but the
grubby politics
in other words says john cornyn anyone
who disagrees with me is low and
unethical
now if you're not used to hearing
liberal demagoguery like that from
republicans you should know that john
cornyn is not the only one engaging in
it he has joined in this effort by tom
tillis of north carolina roy blunt of
missouri rob portman of ohio richard
burr of north carolina mitt romney of
course of utah bill cassidy of louisiana
susan collins of maine needless to say
lindsey graham of south carolina always
on board for any bad idea and pat toomey
of pennsylvania it's particularly
interesting to see lindsey graham on
board the person who encouraged capitol
hill police to shoot more trump voters
who has no problem with violence whose
life is organized around worshiping it
telling you that you can't have a gun
now all the senators whose names we just
read many of whom are retiring so
they're beyond the reach of voters have
the backing of the top republican in the
senate mitch mcconnell
so what exactly are they backing when
they back red flag laws well we can take
florida's experience as an example in
florida the police can seize guns from
people who pose a quote significant
danger based on quote any relevant
evidence
huh
that's it
any relevant evidence the law raises
some obvious questions and the most
obvious is
if you can seize people's guns
without proving that they committed a
crime why can't you imprison them
without proving they committed a crime
if you can take their guns why can't you
take their homes why can't you empty
their bank accounts ooh sound paranoid
alex jones stuff that just happened in
canada
so what stops it from happening here
we already know the authorities are
abusing the red flag laws already on the
books kendra paris is a lawyer based in
florida who specializes in them in a
recent interview she said clients are
able to hire lawyers have quote vastly
higher odds of getting their firearms
back from the government of course
laws like this always penalize the
weakest she said courts are taking a
quote better safe than sorry approach to
avoid political blowback and the police
are taking advantage of that so court
records show that cops in florida often
show up to the homes of citizens who
present them with quote stipulations if
you agree in writing to surrender your
firearms you have a chance of getting
them back after a year
now as it happens that's a pretty
tempting offense offer when you have
armed people in your living room but it
is and it remains and again we don't
need to guess about it because the
supreme court just ruled on this it's
unconstitutional
and it is for several reasons it's a
clear violation of the search and
seizure prohibition and the fourth
amendment but it's also applied unfairly
and even the people who wrote our
current red flag laws admit that in new
york for example assembly member joanne
simon co-sponsored the state's red flag
law quote basically it's all over the
place simon admitted you have places
where you have one file to other places
where it's 38 filed
so how will these laws be applied well
of course they will be applied along
political lines just like everything
else currently is in this highly
politicized country
so if you don't like someone if you
don't like what someone believes that
person will be a target for
unconstitutional search and seizure
armed authorities showing up in
somebody's home and taking their
personal property at gunpoint
and if you doubt that that will happen
look at this
this is the guy the very same member of
congress who had sex with a chinese spy
demanding that cops disarm ben shapiro
because ben shapiro says things the
chinese government disagrees with this
is from eric swalwell quote please tell
me this lunatic does not own a gun
reason number one 1578 that america
needs red flag laws
erickson wrote that
now what would qualify as a trigger for
gun seizure in the view of eric
swellwell under the red flag laws that
he supports and now republicans in the
senate support
well here's the video that ben shapiro
made that swalwell thinks qualifies him
for a red flag law watch
if you come to tell me that you're going
to indoctrinate my kids in particular
policy and that i can't pull my kid out
of the school and send my kids to a
school i want to send them to that i
can't go to the church or synagogue that
i want to go to
and if you make that national policy not
just california policy where i can move
but national policy
people are not going to stand for that i
have two choices one is to leave the
country utterly two is to pick up a gun
those are the only choices that you have
left me and now people on like oh this
is how could you say stuff like that how
could you be so extreme
it's not extreme to defend the
fundamental rights the constitution was
created in order to protect
these rights pre-exist government
these rights pre-exist government well
actually our founding documents make
that point which he is merely repeating
but on the basis of effectively quoting
the founding documents of the country we
live in
eric swallow says the police should show
up at ben shapiro's house and take his
firearms away does anybody even eric
swalwell who is deranged sincerely
believe that ben shapiro is a violent
threat to anyone no of course not
benchmare was an ideological threat and
an ideological threat is the only kind
of threat people like eric swallow
actually care about
and you know that
when you look at the laws that they're
pushing and the republicans are backing
if these laws were actually designed to
fight
gun crime they would among other things
force prosecutors to enforce existing
gun laws against people who are
committing all the murders and it's not
been shapiro
in los angeles and many other cities
that's not happening and that's why
those criminals openly support the
soros-backed prosecutor george gascon
watch
i told you last time that he won her up
and tried to get something dead before
they
re-elect somebody else besides gascone
and bring back that little uh
the life without parole and
the death penalty if you could get the
man slaughtered
manslaughter only carried six nine and
twelve
yeah so that's just one tape we could
play you video as we often do of what's
happening in our city so what you're
looking at is antarctica tyranny
so people who are favored by the regime
can do whatever they want you vote the
right way commit whatever crimes you
want in jail for 10 minutes you're out
go do it again no problem baltimore can
happen mass killings on an ongoing basis
for decades and no one will say a word
but if you're disfavored
by the regime
no punishment is too strong no
infraction too small
none of the gun legislation that john
cornyn and these other pompous buffoons
who were siding with nancy pelosi
support none of that legislation would
do anything about the core problem which
is da's like george gascone who are
failing to enforce existing gun laws
gun laws that by the way george gascon
himself to name one example is breaking
a whistleblower in gascon's office says
he was fired for complaining about
gascon's habit of illegally carrying
firearms aboard airplanes
so why haven't the cops red-flagged
george gascone and disarmed him was
anyone going to red flag hunter biden
who lied on a federal drug forum
was a drug addict carrying an illegally
obtained weapon no
of course not because red flag laws
aren't designed to punish the
politically loyal
and that's why you get scenes like this
in new orleans which the police do
nothing about watch
[Music]
tell your shot to get get the car going
to slide
[Music]
so
hey
john cornyn will your legislation do
anything about that
because anybody who's okay with that or
what's happening in downtown chicago or
downtown baltimore gary indiana detroit
pick a city
every day of the week
fix those things and get back to me
about the ar in my closet
by the way in new orleans the soros back
da there jason williams isn't worried
about what you just saw last year his
office dismissed more than 60 percent of
violent felony cases that came to his
office most of them involving firearms
they just dismissed them these people
worry about gun crime
for perspective the previous
administration dismissed only 16 of
those cases
another source back da in philadelphia
has a similar record in the first half
of last year larry krasner's office
withdrew or dismissed
65 percent of all gun charges does that
seem high well it is because in 2015
that figure was just 17
new ideology
new outcome and of course the outcome is
more dead people but this law does
nothing about that it ignores it
completely in favor of redefining you as
a violent threat and giving the
authorities
controlled by the buy demonstration the
right to march into your house with guns
drawn and disarm you
so what are they ignoring well let's see
last year in philadelphia
we saw a record set for homicides
already this year more than 200 people
have been shot to death in the city of
philadelphia which is not a huge city
and it's getting smaller on friday for
example a 14 year old boy was killed in
a drive-by on saturday a man was shot
five times in west philadelphia did you
see that on the news probably not on
something on sunday night a man taking
care of his mother in north philadelphia
was shot in the back of the head
so if you're actually worried about gun
crimes gun atrocities and for the record
we are
because unlike lindsey graham we
actually hate violence you would do
something about this and punish the
people who are committing gun crimes
but no
they want to prevent you from defending
your family from buying or holding guns
why is that
well we don't need to guess because
they're telling us
watch with the attorney general of the
united states and just to restate this
guy actually is the attorney general
he's more than a craven political act he
runs the doj watch him describe mr
merrick garland the biggest threat
facing this country today
in the fbi's view the top domestic
violent extremist threat comes from
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race
that's just a total lie actually and we
have numbers to prove it but you know
it's a lie there's no justification
rationally for what merrick garland just
said it's ridiculous it's an obvious
untruth that anyone living in a major
city knows that
so why
do they keep telling you that
well because nothing that by
administration is doing and nothing that
is happening in congress right now will
actually address
gun violence
that's not the point john cornyn
the point is to allow the democratic
party to become even more powerful and
if it feels like it to send its armed
agents to raid the homes of ben shapiro
and other disobedient people the
democratic party doesn't like
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight